we unleashed something powerful DHS we
brought this together
there is another person I can think of
maybe I'm doing it wrong you have no
idea what I'm capable
she just wanted to give me a hug wish me
luck really
watch this
sorry I'm messing around
wish I had a suit
even with like minimal powers or maybe
even just the soup with no powers yeah
so how long have you been Antonin again
no huh and just sort of happened
I wish trick it's like bad guys like you
[Music]
and I seem to mess it up almost every
time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch for
back
like a person
[Music]
back to pen I actually heard what
happened to you you open up the quantum
realm that's when he's crazy could be
ghostly like walks two walls of stuff
so Leo tech now supposed to take over
the world or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn the house at
me because we robbed you do you remember
that's us
peel and chefs we practice this pose
again
and man and the wasp teaming up follow
my lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
[Music]
hey what'd I miss
we were just tiny I was partners with
Hank on a project called Goliath how big
did you get my record 21 feet you've 65
feet 65 if you to our finish comparing
sizes 65
[Music]
you